Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible] these days.
We see so many amazing uses for learning based algorithms from enhancing
computer animations, teaching virtual animals,
to walk to teaching self-driving cars, depth perception,
and more,
it truly feels like no field of science is left untouched by these new
techniques, including the medical sciences you see in medical imaging.
A common problem is that we have so many diagnostic images out there in the wild
that it makes it more and more infeasible for doctors to look at all of them.
What you see here is a work from scientists at DeepMind health that we covered a
few hundred episodes ago.
The training part takes about 14,000 optical coherence, tomography scans.
This is the OCT label that you see on the left.
These images are cross sections of the human retina.
We first start out with this OCD scan,
then a manual segmentation step follows where a Dr. Marks up this
image to show where the relevant parts,
lighter retinal fluids or the elevations of the retinal pigments are
after the learning process.
This method can reproduce the segmentations really well by itself
without the doctor's supervision.
And you see here that the two images are almost identical in these tests.
Now that we have the segmentation map, it is time to perform classification.
This means that we look at this map and assign a probability to each possible
condition that may be present. Finally, based on these,
a final verdict is made whether the patient needs to be urgently seen or
just a routine check, or perhaps no check is required.
This was an absolutely incredible piece of work. However,
it is of utmost importance to evaluate these tools together with experienced
doctors and hopefully on international datasets,
since then in this new work,
deep mind has knocked the evaluation out of the park for a system they developed
to detect breast cancer as early as possible.
Let's briefly talk about the technique and then try to explain why it is
sinfully difficult to evaluate it properly. So onto the new problem,
these mammograms contain four images that show the breasts from two different
angles.
And the goal is to predict whether the biopsy taken later will be positive for
cancer or not.
This is especially important because early detection is key for treating these
patients. And the key question is how does it compare to the expert?
Have a look here.
This is a case of cancer that was missed by all six experts in the study,
but was correctly identified by the AI. And what about this one?
This case didn't work so well. It was caught by all six experts,
but was missed by the AI.
So one reassuring sample and one failed sample. And with this,
we have arrived to the central thesis of the paper, which asks the question.
What does it really take to say that an AI system surpassed human
experts to even have a fighting chance in tackling this?
We have to measure false positives and false negatives.
The false positive means that the AI mistakenly predicts that a sample is
positive. When in reality it is negative.
The false negative means that the AI thinks that the sample is negative,
whereas it is positive. In reality.
The key is that in every decision domain,
the permissible rates for false negatives and positives is different.
Let me try to explain this through this example in cancer detection,
if we have a sick patient who gets classified as healthy is a grave mistake that
can lead to serious consequences.
But if we have a healthy patient who is misclassified as sick,
the positive cases,
get a second look from a doctor who can easily identify the mistake.
The consequences in this case are much less problematic and can be remedied by
spending a little time checking the samples that the AI was less confident about
the bottom line is that there are many different ways to interpret the data.
And it is by no means trivial to find out which one is the right way to do
so. And now hold onto your papers because here comes the best part.
If we compare the predictions of the AI to the human experts,
we see that the false positive cases in the U S have been reduced by
5.7% while the false negative cases
have been reduced by 9.7%.
That is the Holy grail.
We don't need to consider the cost of false positives or negatives here because
it reduced false positives and false negatives at the same time.
Spectacular.
Another important details is that these numbers came out of an independent
evaluation.
It means that the results did not come from the scientists who wrote the
algorithm and have been thoroughly checked by independent experts who have no
vested interest in this project.
This is the reason why you see so many authors on this paper. Excellent.
Another interesting tidbit is that the AI was trained on subjects from the UK.
And the question was,
how well does this knowledge generalize for subjects from other places?
For instance,
the United States is this UK knowledge reusable in the U S
I have been quite surprised by the answer because it never saw a sample from
anyone in the us and still did better than the experts on us data.
This is a very assuring property,
and they hope to see some more studies that show how general the knowledge is
that these systems are able to obtain through training.
And perhaps the most important, if you remember one thing from this video,
let it be the following.
This work much like other AI infused medical solutions are not made
to replace human doctors.
The goal is instead to empower them and take off as much weight
from their shoulders as possible.
We have hard numbers for this as the results concluded that this work reduces
this workload of the doctors by 88%,
which is an incredible result among other far-reaching consequences.
I would like to mention that this would substantially help not only the work of
doctors in wealthier, more developed countries,
but it may single-handedly enable proper cancer detections in more developing
countries who cannot afford to check these scans and note that in this video,
we truly have just scratched the surface.
Whatever we talk about here in a few minutes cannot be a description as rigorous
and accurate as the paper itself.
So make sure to check it out in the video description. And with that,
I hope you'll now have a good feel of the pace of progress in machine learning
research. The retinal fluid project was state of the art in 2018,
and now less than two years later,
we have a proper independently evaluated AI based detection for
breast cancer and Bravo deep mind what a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by Linode Linode is the world's largest
independent cloud computing provider.
And like entry-level hosting services Linode gives you full backend access to
your server, which is your step-up to powerful, fast,
fully configurable cloud computing.
Linode also has one-click apps that streamline your ability to deploy websites,
personal VPNs, game servers, and more,
if you need something as small as a personal online portfolio,
Linode has your back.
And if you need to manage tons of clients' websites and reliably serve them to
millions of visitors, Linode can do that too. What's more,
they offer affordable GPU instances featuring the Quadro RDX
6,000,
which is tailor made for AI scientific computing and computer graphics
projects.
If only I had access to a tool like this while I was working on my last few
papers to receive $20 in credit on your newly anode account, visit
leno.com/papers,
or click the link in the video description and give it a try today.
Our thanks to Linode for supporting the series and helping us make better videos
for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.